foreign
Northern Ireland police officer is in a
critical but stable condition after
being shot several times last night at a
Youth Sports Complex in Omar he was off
duty coaching football so it happened in
front of Young Players let's find out
more about it the incident happened it's
been condemned by politicians across the
political divide despite the opposing
party's Sinn Fein and dup having
contrasting political views they can
both agree that this act was Despicable
I think a lot like the rest of the
community I am absolutely shocked and
stunned out what happened here this
evening you know this was a Despicable
and shameful attack on a police officer
in front of perhaps hundreds of young
people at this Sport and Recreation Hub
here in Uma
I have been told by one person react
they saw the flashes going out of the
gun
as they fired at the police officer this
is this is a Despicable act this is one
that must be condemned
by everyone every race thinking person
but condemnation is one thing people
must be brought to Justice For What
they've done
well the Prime Minister Rishi sunak has
extended his sympathies to the officer
and his family in a tweet this morning
I'm appalled by the disgraceful shooting
of an off-duty police officer in Omar my
thoughts are with the officer and his
family there is no place in our society
for those who seek to harm public
servants protecting communities
well our Island correspondent Stephen
Murphy is at the scene for us Stephen
what more do we know about what happened
well overnight the Police Service of
Northern Ireland have confirmed they
have now launched a full attempted
murder investigation they also confirmed
in a statement released in the small
hours uh that the police officer that
was attacked here at this Sports Complex
on the outskirts of Omar was struck
multiple times uh in that attack our
Witnesses here had spoken of uh seeing
or hearing at least half a dozen
gunshots in this callus and cowardly
attack on a very senior and a very well
respected police officer the Pearson I
have not officially named him yet so
therefore the media is not reporting his
name but everybody here knows who he is
he's incredibly well liked he's well
involved in the local community he's a
senior member of the psni as well and I
think you got a sense over there from
the clips K you played uh from Tom and
Declan who I spoke to here at the scene
a while ago but the sense here in the
local community is really one of utter
revulsion people are just revolted that
not only would somebody or some people
try to essentially assassinate a police
officer here in their local community
but that they chose this place to do it
this is a Haven it's a community Hub
it's across Community facility people
from both sides of the traditional
divide come here with their children uh
Gala games are played here as well as
football and we believe the officer was
actually involved in voluntary coaching
uh last night at around eight o'clock
that session was drawing to a close
there were lots of children here and
that's when reportedly two Mass gunmen
approached
picked out their Target in a very
deliberous Manner and opened fire as we
as you mentioned there he is in a
critical condition it was described as
critical but stable at the old McGavin
Area Hospital in Derry or Londonderry
widespread condemnation of this attack
but the people here want to see whoever
was responsible for this brought to
Justice at this early stage it is too
early to say whether it's a distant
Republican attack or something maybe of
a more organized criminal element but
Simon burned the chief Constable the top
police officer in Northern has vowed to
relentlessly pursue those responsible
okay thank you
Ukraine's foreign minister has told Sky
News his country would not use Western
fighter jets for attacks on Russian soil
that comes as the United Nations
prepares to vote on a resolution later
today against Russian aggression iOS
correspondent Mark Stone reports
it may be seen as the ultimate talking
shop but then at least they are talking
in here the Chamber of the United
Nations is the only place where both
sides in this conflict are in the same
room it's not that they're talking to
each other of course or even sharing the
same version of reality because from
Russia it is a breathtaking rewriting of
History
we had no other option other than
defending the people of donbass and
ensuring the Safety and Security of our
country using military means
the purpose of this emergency General
Assembly meeting is to vote on a
resolution later today a symbolic
demonstration of unity against Russian
aggression a year after its invasion of
Ukraine what Ukraine really wants indeed
what we all want
we have continually called for
is a just peace
this vote will go down in history
on the one-year anniversary of this
conflict we will see where the nations
of the world stand on the matter of
Peace in Ukraine
weapons for Ukraine to finish the war
Remains the top priority for its foreign
minister but a western reluctance
lingers do you accept that the concern
in the west if you have fighter jets you
will strike Russia proper and then you
will create a much much wider conflict
we are using weapons which we receive
from Partners to strike Russia in the
occupied territories of Ukraine and you
can guarantee you won't strike Russia in
its uh itself we can guarantee that we
will be using Western weapons to
liberate Ukrainian territories the top
diplomats of the security Council will
meet tomorrow Britain America Russia
China among them on the wall outside
their chamber Picasso's violent
depiction of a past war is the blunt
intentional reminder to them all of the
cost in Ukraine today Mark Stone Sky
News at the UN in New York
and the Ukrainian president has praised
the UK as he called for more urgent
Military Support Vladimir zielinski said
he'd spoken to the Prime Minister about
greater cooperation
we are working very hard together with
Britain to strengthen our soldiers to
bring our joint Victory closer to
implement our defense agreements that
were reached during my visit to London
and it would be great if all our
partners understood as well as Britain
how the speed of our defense Supply
affects concrete successes on the
battlefield
for his 19 hi Deborah good morning to
you
um the ukrainians saying if you give us
your fighter jets we won't use them over
Russian airspace is that right
yes well it's saying that they won't use
any Western weapons to attack Russia
proper of course all these weapons are
necessary if um if Ukraine is going to
stand a chance of of pushing through
um very well defended now Russian lines
in the East and there's been uh the
latest update from the UK's Ministry of
defense and their defense intelligence
saying this morning that there is still
Fierce fighting going on around that
city of bakmut in Donetsk and also
saying that Russia is is continuing to
Shell again another town called in that
area it's a place actually where the
Russians suffered a heavy defeat heavy
casualties earlier in the month but a
sign that Russian forces are still
intensifying their effort to break
through Ukrainian lines all ahead of
this awful Milestone one year of
full-scale War which both sides will be
marking tomorrow and there is concerns
here in the capital that Russia which
does like dates might seek to choose to
use the 24th of February to launch
another maybe even more significant
volley of missile strikes there's no
chance of it trying to strike the
capital with land forces anytime soon
but you'll have to remember that's what
it did try last year everybody
anticipating at that time that it might
be a lightning strike on Keith that was
defeated but this war shows no end in
sight yeah just a thought on the Russian
airspace and the fighter jets Etc
um Russia of course has already made
claim to some parts of Ukraine what
would happen if those Jets were flying
over that airspace
well they Russia would view them as a
legitimate Target and would shoot them
down I mean the problem we've got really
in terms of Western Jets is that no
Western country has yet given them to
Ukraine and unless that does happen
um then it's kind of is sort of
hypothetical but in theory yes if
Ukraine's Air Force was given Western
Jets then they would become legitimate
targets for Russia in the same way that
Western tanks are going to become
legitimate targets as soon as they enter
the battlefield and already the multiple
launch rocket systems for example that
are here are seen as legitimate targets
okay for now thank you in other news the
Israeli military say Palestinian
militants have fired six Rockets from
the Gaza Strip toward the south of the
country early this morning this comes
just hours after an Israeli raid in the
occupied West Bank City of nablos in
which 11 Palestinians were killed let's
get more on this with Alistair standing
by for us in Jerusalem this morning
Aleister what prompted this
what prompted it was a massive Israeli
raid in the West Bank city of Nablus
yesterday morning now it was unusual
because when the Israeli military carry
out raids in the West Bank they tend to
do it before Dawn or during the middle
of the night so they've got the cover of
Darkness but they went in they say
because of intelligence that led them to
believe that a number of militants will
hold up in a house in nablas's Old City
they asked them to surrender we're told
but a gun battle then ensued and the
fact that it was during the middle of
the day meant that also the perimeter
forces uh there to try and secure Nablus
whilst this raid was going on they also
came under Fire were told from Cars
motorbikes and from rooftops and so all
in all what I think the IDF hoped would
be a fairly straightforward Mission
ended up in a very deadly four-hour gun
battle in which 11 people were killed
all of them Palestinians and more than a
hundred wounded there were no IDF of
cash cities I should point out
overnight six Rockets were fired from
the Gaza Strip five of those were
intercepted by Israel's Iron Dome
missile defense system one of them
landed short in response the IDF then
carried out their own airstrikes on two
weapons Depots in the Gaza Strip now
nobody was injured in this exchange of
Rocket fire which is normally an
indication that it was a game of
messaging between the two sides if you
like
in terms of what happened last night we
expected that we were sort of on alert
as were the Israelis for that exchange
of Rocket fire the question is though in
light of what happened in Nablus
yesterday and the high death toll there
and in light of the deteriorating
security situation is this now the start
of something more
Alistair for now thank you
in other news thousands of Asylum cases
are to be fast tracked in a bid to cut
the soaring backlog uh let's get more
should we uh Becky's standing by for us
here in the studio hi Becky good morning
how does this work so what we know is
there will be a questionnaire sent out
to Asylum Seekers and it's understood
that 12 000 of those Asylum Seekers will
be eligible for their assigned claim to
be granted just on the basis of this uh
questionnaire no interview now it's
thought that these Asylum Seekers will
be from Afghanistan Syria Eritrea Libya
and Yemen people from those countries
already have a very high rate of Asylum
approval here about 95 now this is all
part of the prime minister's pledge to
clear the Asylum claim backlog that
would have meant clearing about 90 000
claims by the end of this year what will
the questionnaire look like well we
understand it will be 10 pages long
around 40 questions now that has led to
Critics on one side saying well hang on
if Asylum Seekers don't speak English
how are they supposed to fill out this
question yeah exactly also concerns um
there's a letter that's been seen by Sky
News from the home office show saying
that potentially if this questionnaire
isn't filled out within 20 working days
a claim could be rejected so concerns
about fairness people falling through
the gaps you've also got Critics on the
other side calling this an amnesty an
all but name some of them on the Tory
bat benches they're also concerned that
this could actually encourage more
people to make that dangerous journey
across the channel something the Prime
Minister has promised to put a stop to
and questions about how you verify if
someone is from where they say they are
from if they don't have ID also
suggestions in that letter from the home
office official that this scheme could
be extended to more Asylum seekers in
due course we know it's already inciting
strong opinions from both politicians
and campaigners and amnesty and all but
no one wonders why they're not calling
it that there you go yeah that's what
the critics are saying yeah it's good to
see you thanks very much indeed thank
you put that to the minister in just a
moment or two excuse me meantime let's
have a look at some of the other
headlines for you at least uh four
people have died 49 are missing
following the collapse of a Coal Mine in
Northern China a rescue mission was
suspended following an additional
landslide in the inner Mongolia region
a man accused of fatally shooting a 20
year old woman in Florida is accused of
returning to the scene and killing a TV
reporter and a nine-year-old girl 19
year old Keith Melvin Moses was arrested
on suspicion of both shootings in the
Orlando area a TV crew member and the
girl's mother are in a critical
condition after being wounded in the
second shooting
elsewhere in the U.S including Wyoming
snow and ice are creating treacherous
conditions on the roads dash cam footage
shows the driver of this Lorry
jackknifing whoops there you go before
his vehicle comes off the motorway
women are now approaching the point of
the Year where they stop working for
free according to the TUC it says the 15
gender gap effectively means women must
work for about two months before they
begin to make the equivalent of the
average male worker
public support for the government's
handling of the NHS in England has
plummeted to its lowest level in two
decades
polling from ipsos and the health
Foundation shows fewer than one in 10
people in England think the UK
government has the right NHS policies
in Scotland more people 28 believe their
devolved government is getting things
right with health
while the figure sat at 90 percent
amongst Welsh respondents
now more of us may struggle to buy our
five a day Tesco and ALDI are the latest
supermarkets to put limits on the sale
of some fruit and vegetables supplies
are short mainly due to bad weather in
southern Europe and North Africa where
much of our winter produce comes from
some of what's coming up in the show
we'll talk about Russia's economy with a
man who knows more about it than most
the financier bill Browder
also this hour the former Chief exec of
the Football Association Mark Palios
will give us his thoughts on the biggest
shake-up of the game in decades
and we look to get some hints from
Labor's Lisa namdi about what's in
today's Landmark speech by her boss
Sakia starber
[Music]
now football in England facing its
biggest shake-up since the Premier
League was formed the aim is to make
sure clubs are better run and that fans
are given a greatest say well a new
independent regulator will be set up to
help prevent a repeated Financial
failing scene at Derby County Berry and
Macclesfield town
there'll be new tests to try to protect
clubs from unscrupulous ownership
fans will be given more input in how
clubs are run including protecting a
club's Heritage and there'll be powers
to block English clubs from joining
Breakaway leagues let's talk about it in
more detail shall we the Parliamentary
under Secretary of State for sport
Stuart Andrew is with us hi it's good to
see you thanks for joining us on the
program so what's the idea behind all of
this then so we commissioned a fan-led
review that was spent a considerable
amount of time speaking to fan groups
and looking at football and it was clear
that whilst there's lots to celebrate
about English football it's very
successful in many areas they're clearly
some serious problems and it's made a
number of recommendations we've taken
time to look at those recommendations
and we are publishing a white paper
today which is designed to bring more
stability to English football and so
that we can enjoy it or fans can enjoy
it as much as they can for the for now
into the future really what's it got to
do with the government who owns a
football club well we would have
preferred frankly for football to have
dealt with this themselves but they
haven't this has been going on a long
time we've seen over the last 20 years
you know over 60 clubs go into
Administration that has a profound
impact on fans it has a profound impact
on the communities in which those clubs
are based and so it is right that we now
set up an independent regulator this
isn't going to be government running
football this will be an independent
regulator that will assess the the
finances of the clubs make sure that
they're stable just about the finances
so it's about the finances it's about
making sure that the people who are
running the club off pass a you know a
proper fit a fit right I mean we'll sell
arms to Saudi Arabia but you don't want
them to own football clubs what so that
will be for the regulator we'll be
looking at each of the people that are
wanting to buy the clubs making sure
that they have prop business plans in
place their finances it's got to be
about money as well but making sure the
finances are there that are sustainable
to keep that club going that they're not
taking risks on those clubs because
these are really it's just about the
money no no no there's there's other
stuff as well like protecting the club
Heritage that is really important you
know you're saying Saudis should own
football clubs or not I'm not saying who
should own a football club or not it
will be up to the independent regulator
to assess that those people that are
wanting to invest in clubs have the best
interest of those clubs at heart they
have the right finances in place and
that that money we they know exactly
where that money has come from so that
we can bring stability to those clubs
and to bring stability to the football
pyramid it'll be retrospective so what
will happen is they will have to apply
for a license to play a professional
football in this country and if they
haven't been retrospective well if they
don't meet though I'm coming to that
point if they don't meet the
requirements they will have to
demonstrate that they are on a path to
meeting the requirements of the
independent regulator so that they can
then fully play football in this country
and that's what we want to see clubs
like Newcastle and Manchester City will
have to retrospectively pass these tests
all anybody who wants to play
professional football will have to apply
for a license to do that they will have
to pass these tests what about human
rights
that that the job I'm not going to talk
it depends what you're talking about
here right I think we know what I'm
talking and we're talking about
um clubs uh Saudi Arabia chopping up
journalists when they're still alive
with a meat saw and we're talking about
uh catter not having appropriate human
rights for people so I I'm not talking
about I can't go into individuals that
will be at this stage because it will be
for the regulator the independent
regulations so my view I mean my view is
that I want to see uh football in this
country being run in the best interests
of football and our fans and we will
does that include clubs uh being owned
by countries that do not have
appropriate human rights my my job is to
ensure that we have the proper
regulatory framework in place and that's
what we're supposed to do today you know
the sports news I want to know what you
think so look I I've made my views very
clear I went to Qatar because I felt you
know that it was important for me to
stand up about you know having inclusive
sport for all that isn't the issue here
is ensuring that we know exactly who
owns the clubs at the moment Sometimes
some clubs don't even know who the
actual owner is and so under this regime
that we will have we will know exactly
who owns that club who that individual
is ensure that we know where that money
is coming from and that they have the
best interests of those clubs at heart I
think this is a really good news story
because it will really help well of
course that's why you're talking about
it but I'm trying to drill down into the
detail you're the sports Minister you're
responsible for football I'm asking you
whether it's appropriate that clubs who
have dispute well not even disputed
terrible human rights records should be
allowed to own football clubs that are
at the breathing heart of this country
that's but the point I'm getting at is
we it will we will know the individual
who is who will own that club and they
will have to pass that test of whether
they are a fit and proper person to to
own a football club that it will be down
to an individual and then we will know
through that
well I'm not really it's not for me to
say whether which country they come from
I mean we have investment in this
country on a wide range of of businesses
I'm not it's not for me to say just
because they're from a certain country
that they shouldn't own a football club
that would be inappropriate what is
approach so it is about making sure that
the right people are are running our
football clubs we know who those people
are we know where their monies come from
and they have passed those fit and
proper persons tests okay talk to me
about what's happening with um excuse me
uh 10 000 refugees being basically given
an amnesty they're not being given an
amnesty
um what is happening here is that the
you know it is important that we look at
the people that have been waiting for
the you know the sort of uh cases to be
heard for a long time this is an
opportunity for them to fill in these
forms to explain you know the sort of
reasons why they're seeking Asylum those
will be assessed and then a decision
will be made is to try and deal with the
backlog that has been happening for too
long how will it be in lots of different
languages not just English those forms
so they will be able to you know work
with home office officials to ensure
that they can fill in those forms that
is an important element but this is to
deal with a problem that is frankly
existed for too long uh what about the
other 80 000 that are also waiting so
this is the start of the process the
Prime Minister has been very clear that
he wants to deal with this and he is
working at PACE I mean he is meeting the
Home Secretary literally every week
going through this whole system because
his priority is to tackle the small
boats issue this is one of those
elements of it so to get through this
list as quickly as possible so it is
fast tracking people it's not fast
tracking they will be checked but it's
to make sure that the process is sped up
it's fed up well but it doesn't mean
that fast tracking means yeah it doesn't
mean that they will not go through you
know the the proper
diligence test that's the important bit
will they have will they have
face-to-face interviews
so at the moment I haven't seen the
detail of that but I know for a fact
that these four this is a way of dealing
with people that frankly uh have been
waiting for too long we've you know
we've rightly had criticism about that
this is a way to deal with it it will be
checked properly
um what's going to happen to shamima
begum are we still going to be in this
position in 30 years time so it wouldn't
be appropriate for me to make a comment
on a case that is live judgment has been
made that judgment has been made and we
I'm not going to be drawn on it's not
live because the decisions been made no
but you know I think this is an
important the court has made its ruling
but it wouldn't be appropriate for me to
make any further comment on that at this
stage why not it's just I'm not going to
make a comment on this at this time okay
it's good to talk to you thanks very
much thank you and let's have a look at
what the paper's doing this morning
should we and starting with the express
reports on what it writes is a Crackdown
on the Asylum Seeker backlog while the
mail reports on a row about the
potential fast tracking of Asylum
Seekers
um the telegraph carries a warning from
BT which says the Chancellor's planned
corporation tax rise is a threat to
investment and growth the I reports at
the Royal College of Nursing has upset
other unions with its willingness to
directly engage with the government over
strike action annamura meets Russian
mercenaries fighting on behalf of
Vladimir Putin in Ukraine it also has a
picture of Diana Charles and baby
William in photos previously on scene by
the public
now the U.S defense department has
released a new image of the Chinese spy
balloon shot down by the U.S military
earlier on this month it was taken from
the cockpit of a U2 spy plane on the 3rd
of February the day before it was shot
down off the coast of South Carolina it
reportedly flew over a number of
sensitive military sites before that
a mysterious metal ball has washed up on
a beach in Japan baffling authorities
and residents it was spotted on the
coastline of hamamatsu City prompting
the police to scramble the bomb squad
but explosives experts don't believe
there's any immediate threat
look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
overnight cloud and rain will be slow to
clear Southern Parts but for much of the
country there'll be a much cooler feel
to the day
sponsored by Qatar Airways
extreme weather conditions everywhere at
the moment let's look at
um
what that's doing there we go there we
go uh global warming here you go 1.26
degrees and now above um previous levels
in the 1880 we're using a little bit
more coal today than we were yesterday
and this is the CO2 emissions in
millions of tons
in live real terms
uh here's something to get you talking
what are top triggers for squabbles
around the house
apparently the home security firm Yale
had pollsters asked 2 000 people and the
results
um will they be surprising not turning
off the lights not walking down kitchen
surfaces wet towels mine uh what to
watch on the Telly and who pays the
bills
there you go it's one of those you
now have you ever heard of dark sky
Sanctuary it's a rare honor we're told
and it's just been bestowed upon bards
the island off North Wales dark sky
sanctuaries are in remote locations
where there's little to no light
pollution as this time lapse basically
shows you giving spectacular views of
the Stars the Red Bull you see that's 70
miles across the Irish sea in Dublin the
Island's main source of light pollution
it joins 16 other sites in a handful of
countries including Australia South
Africa and the us if you ever go on
Safari you will see Dark Skies there
there's absolutely no light pollution
um let's find out what's happening in
politics today tomorrow is standing by
obscure is going to make a speech Yes
another one kirst armor is making a big
speech this morning and this is going to
be the five things that are going to
form Labor's Labor's election Manifesto
so the five key points and I spoke to
labor sources this morning who tell me
that the top one is going to be be
securing the highest economic growth of
any G7 country of course Britain has
been forecast to have the lowest
economic growth of any of those
economies this year although forecasts
can of course be wrong and the other
four priorities are going to be making
Britain a clean energy superpower so
climate change also the NHS crime and
education now kirstama has set out a
number of priorities before and he's
going to use similar language in terms
of this being the project of a decade a
decade of national renewal it all sounds
very long term and the question that's
going to be thrown at him is if people
vote labor what can they expect
immediately if they get into government
and I'm told that over the next few
weeks he will be going into detail about
each of those things and setting out
more measurable goals but his whole idea
is that it's taken a very long time it's
going to take a very long time to fix
what labor says the mess the
conservatives have made of the economy
and public services and so they're
unashamedly thinking in the long term
about how to turn things around of
course the Prime Minister announced five
goals as well back in January focusing
more on immigration and getting the
national debt down so that's not in Kia
stormers at Five Points and so it will
be the battle of the five-point plans I
think when it comes to the next general
election okay let's see for now thanks
very much indeed thank you a British man
captured by the Russians while fighting
alongside Ukrainian troops As Told Sky
News how he was tortured and left unable
to walk Sean Penner was among five
britons released in a prisoner swap last
September uh he's been speaking to Beth
Rigby
wading through the trenches of Mario
Paul Southeastern Ukraine Sean Penner a
former British soldier part of the
Ukrainian Army since 2018 filming here
with Sky News just weeks before the
outbreak of war and his capture by
Russian forces
now safely back in the UK with his
family but memories of recent months and
the anniversary of the Russian invasion
Loom large where were you what happened
how quickly did it build up well we got
stood two about four o'clock in the
morning and we knew something was
happening my boss had just spoke speaks
really good English says you've got to
get to positions Russia come across the
border
yeah it's on what happens in that moment
your adrenaline's going you're nervous
you're scared you know part of people
aren't scared I was petrified uh it's
Russia
10 days Russian forces Advanced
bombarding
surrounding Mario Paul a city quickly
Under Siege just so intense me and my
team we called it Phil Collins you know
it sounds just like that beat as it
comes in very slow builds up and then
it's but you've been in combat a lot
yeah had you ever seen anything like
this no it was just nothing like the the
carelessness of it the bombing of scores
I saw a score with just the kids uh
coats hanging up and bags on there where
they've been evacuated and put in a
Cellar and they just hit the school
didn't care about it under sustained
attack Sean tried to escape but was
quickly captured by Russian forces made
prisoner detained imprisoned tortured
electrocuted you feel like your muscles
are popping out if you're
um your body and the next day my legs
inflated
fed just bread and water for 50 days and
then accused of being a mercenary
sentenced to death in a Russian proxy
Court later released in a prisoner
Exchange
distressing Reflections a story hard to
hear about a war that wages on Beth
Rigby Sky News
Bill Roger oh um don't forget you can
see more of that on Beth show tonight
Bill Browder is with us financier author
of red notice and freezing order
um good to see you thanks for joining us
are you surprised that this war is still
going on in Ukraine none at all I mean
neither side has any incentive to
compromise in any way Putin can't for
him compromise or negotiation is a sign
of weakness and weakness would be
putting him at risk of losing his power
and he's committed so many gross
atrocities murders rapes destruction of
of territory that the ukrainians have no
willingness to negotiate either and so
both sides are going to fight on neither
side at this point has a decisive
military advantage and so this is just
going to grind on and on and on and I
can imagine we'll be sitting here a year
from now and having the same
conversation how long do you think it
will go on for
I think it'll go on until one side
collapses or the other side collapses
there's you know a victory a Russian
Victory happened because Russia's not
going to collapse and the West is not
going to allow Ukraine to collapse well
um Russia could as the Russian military
could collapse in Ukraine I mean it's
it's basically physics if the ukrainians
can physically push them out of their
country then that's the collapse that
I'm referring to and on the other side
if for example um we stopped supporting
Ukraine we stop giving them military
equipment if the if if there's a change
in government in America let's say
Donald Trump becomes president and says
I don't want to support Ukraine anymore
and there are voices on the far right in
America that are suggesting that
um that could lead to the collapse of
the Ukrainian uh counter-offensive
um what about we spoke to you I think in
January you said the cleanest safest and
simplest way from deterring Putin from
invading Ukraine is to go after his
money yeah well we didn't do that we
only did that after we invaded so
sanctions um can be very powerful either
as a deterrent which we didn't use or as
a punishment which we are using but the
punishment is it's not going to change
his mind at this point if if we had gun
gone all guns blazing let's say six
months before this actual Invasion he
might have said oh actually the West is
serious he didn't think we were serious
he didn't think that that we would lock
arms altogether and impose these
sanctions he didn't think he was serious
though did we well I think we did think
he was serious he didn't think he would
invade I didn't even think he would
invade but but
um uh he's always been a serious
criminal and a serious murderer I mean I
I've been shouting from the rooftops for
10 years this man is much worse than you
think you should try to do anything you
can to contain him
but we just he invaded Georgia we didn't
do anything he took Crimea we didn't do
anything he carpet bombed Syria we
didn't do anything he poisoned people in
Salisbury we didn't do anything well we
did hardly hardly I mean we didn't
sanction a bunch of oligarchs we kicked
out a few diplomats that were replaced
by other diplomats
to me about how effective you think
sanctions have been the ones that have
been implemented albeit as you say after
the event well there are several
different categories of sanctions we've
Frozen 350 billion dollars of Russian
Central Bank Reserves that's a lot of
money that they could have used for
their war effort that they're not using
we've gone after 40 of the top 118
oligarchs and hundreds of billions of
dollars is now Frozen from that which is
in in my opinion some of Putin's money
we have stopped a bunch of Russian Banks
from from engaging in in financial
activities in the west which means they
can't Finance their war that way which
is helpful but the big problem is
there's one huge elephant in the room
and that's oil and gas
every day Russia sells to the west and
to the east somewhere between 500
million and a billion dollars a day of
oil and gas and that money is used to
pay to kill ukrainians and until we can
figure out what to do with that this war
will go on or I should say Putin can can
Finance this war into perpetuity what
about
um funds being channeled through China
as is the allegation
well what what the bigger and more
serious allegation is that China is
going to start supplying lethal military
equipment to Russia Russia Russia is
running out of arms yeah they're so
they're in such bad shape Russia used to
be a big arms exporter they're in such
bad shape that they've had to go to the
only two countries that are so
sanctioned they don't care North Korea
in Iran if China were to enter the game
and give them weapons that would be a
game changer for Russia that would be
terrible for Ukraine and it could lead
to the Third World War
what is the likelihood of that happening
well um uh Secretary of State Anthony
blinken brought it up at the Munich
security conference last weekend
Chinese representatives in Moscow just
yesterday yeah so now on the other hand
China is a Mercantile country they they
survive off of selling stuff all over
the world to us and many other people
and if they all of a sudden are doing
this nasty sort of you know killing of
Ukraine if we see a Chinese missile an
unexploded missile on the ground in
Ukraine that's going to lead many people
to call for sanctions call for economic
uh countermeasures
and does Russia really want that I mean
it I mean does China really want that
when when that's their economy I mean
you know what's in it for them
um other than poking the NATO America UK
and the eye what do you think will
happen
I think this war will just carry on and
Carry On and carry on I I I just don't
do you think China will help Russia
um with with lethal weapons
is I I don't know I just don't know I
mean I I can't I couldn't have imagined
um China doing even the idea that they
were going to do this and I I just hope
not but I I have it's impossible to say
I I one can't predict the way a dictator
is going to think
stuff thanks very much indeed for
joining us thank you
hello again everybody now let's be blunt
it can be a bit of a challenge turning
40 but one person who is celebrating the
big 4-0 today there she is is Emily
Blunt The Golden Globe winner is best
known for her role in The Devil Wears
Prada and Mary Poppins returns more
recently she's featured opposite her
husband in the horror movie a quiet
place something you might not know is
Emily Blunt's uncle is conservative MP
for Reiger Crispin blunt and her sister
is married to the actor Stanley Tucci
there you go and she looks absolutely
Sensational doesn't she gorgeous no
after a fun-led review into how football
clubs are run the government is planning
the creation of an independent football
regulator in what would be the Sport's
biggest shake-up since the Premier
League was created it's been designed to
keep dodgy owners out and give fans more
input joined Now by former Chief exec of
the fa and current chairman of Tranmere
Rovers Mark Palios um hey Mark it's good
to see you thanks for joining us what do
you think good idea
sorry is it a good idea
uh yes it is I I I I my first response
to it is it's a great start uh because
the motorcycle around I of the Premier
League and uh from what I've seen in the
past is that issues get marched into the
long grass and shot and so they Outlast
the attention span of the current
incumbent of the The Minister's office
Etc so it's great to see that the
government actually followed through on
the Tracy Crouch report there's still a
lot more to be done
but is it
following the money or should it also
take into account
um the I don't know the um the human
rights of the country that the money is
coming from
um I I think you're
um I think you're talking about uh the
the uh the comments as regards whether
owners are fit and proper uh which is
something that I think will be
determined once we get into the
consultation phases because what's going
to happen after this is a consultation
with all the stakeholders and the real
issue I think that's on the table that's
been left to some extent still in the
hands of the the powers that be within
the game is the question of funds flow
down into the pyramid and beyond that
not just into the championship but
actually into the lower leagues as well
and so the governments have whilst
they've done what you would say
um complied with what the populist
issues are you know fans having a
greater say
um not good moving into an on a new
super league for example those types of
things yeah I should say the vote
catches but they are populous purely
because that's what came out from the
people when Tracy Crouch did a review
but the issue in terms of funds flow and
how do you put in place controls because
if you if you just pass more money down
into down the pyramid
um without Financial controls in place I
think you'll just be putting petrol on
the fire so that's where the big debate
will come and of course the regulator
has retained powers to step in if he
feels that the authorities have not come
up with a sensible solution I
know if you heard the minister earlier
on this is what he said about the human
rights issue I'd be interested to hear
your thoughts on that have a quick
listen
so now I'm not saying who should own a
football club or not it will be up to
the independent regulator to assess that
those people that are wanting to invest
in clubs have the best interest of those
clubs at heart they have the right
finances in place and that money we they
know exactly where that money has come
from so that we can bring stability to
those clubs and to bring stability to
the football pyramid we're talking about
clubs Saudi Arabia chopping up
journalists when they're still alive
with a mixer and we're talking about uh
Qatar not having appropriate human
rights for people so I I'm not talking
about I can't go into individuals that
will be at this stage because it will be
for the regulator the independent
regulations so my view I mean my view is
that I want to see uh football in this
country being run in the best interests
of football
what did you think of his answer there
well actually I think he's right I mean
at the end of the day it is the
independent regulator's job the whole
issue about ownership and bad ownership
within the game and there have been
cases of bad ownership and it's not just
about the morals and the ethics of where
the money came from from a particular
State it's about the day-to-day running
of football clubs and that's what down
the lower leagues in the pyramid that's
certainly where there has been a lot of
Heartache with clubs who are a real
asset in the community going to the wall
so there's a there's a there's a there's
a real Focus around that one of the
things I would say though okay and this
is I think this has been slightly missed
by people
um because we always talk about bad
owners there's a lot of good owners who
put a lot of cash into the game itself
and my concern is that at this point in
time
um the focus tends to be towards the top
end of the pyramid and it's the pyramid
that we need to protect because the
pyramid is unique in this country and
people have said you know no other major
sports have a government regulator or
actually no other major thoughts have a
pyramid that looks anything like the the
structure that we have in this country
so The Minister's writing what he says
he he's not an expert in the game we
understand that but it's this
consultation period that will come I
think one of the problems okay is that
we've already waited a year since Tracy
Crouch's report and we really need to
get on with this the the the the
problems that clubs face financially are
issues that are here day to day and will
continue on until we get some changes
how's the team getting on
uh
we've got a young side
um we're inconsistent I'm afraid okay uh
but uh we're hopeful that the tail end
of this season will be uh will be good
okay uh good luck to you thanks for
taking the time to join us thanks thanks
a lot